THE AVALANCHE ARE STILL THE
NUMBER ONE TEAM IN THE WEST.
THE CONDOR. PLAYED BY
VLADAR.
TWO MINUTESTHAT HIT HIM IN THE .
EVENING.
TOUGH ANGLE SHOT.
THAT HIT HIS SKATE.
TOFFOLI IS ABLE TO BAT IT UP WI.
YOU MISSOST AND IT WENT IN,
MUCH
BETTER THAN HE HAS OVER THE
COURSE OF MAYBEBE4
SEASON.
HERE COMES THE CONDOR.
EJ
OF 245 TWO-GAME ROADS TRIP.
L.A. VERY MUCH FROM IT.
DID?
JACK JOHNSON ACROSS THE INBOARDS
AND LUCIC, A BIG HEAVY RIGHT ON.
MAKAR FLASHING IN.
>> NOW -- IT'S TOUGH TO COMPARE
HIM AGAINST LANDESKOG BECAUSE WE
CIRCLE AND SCORE -- NO, NO, NO.E
MAN WITH THE PUCK ON THE SECOND
POWERPLALA IT.
SOME NIGHTS Y Y FLEE BUT HE COUT
UP TO TOFFOLOL FOR ON.
WHAT THE HECK HAPPENED HERE?
THEY WERE GOODNESS.
>> THAT'S ALL PART OF WHY KADRI
IS SO BACK.
KADRI SPINS AWAY FHIS CLOSE TO G
ON TOP 2-0.
>> RIS, LEFT SI
KICKED UP TO THE NEAR SIDE.
GREAT PLAY, GREAT
PUCK TO TANEV.
AVS FORCE THE
YOU GO,ND AND MAKING INCREDIBLE
SAVES TO KEE GAME/PERIOD.
RIGHT OFF
AND THEN HE TRANSFERS IT BEUCIC.
LOOSE PUCK TO LINDHOLM.
WATCH OUT, NOW.U.
SURVEYS, QUICK CENTERING PASS.
THAT'S STUCK   IS -- NOW,
SCORE!
[ HORN ]
>> A
ANDERSSON.
TRIED TO SEND IT FAR SIDE F
>> WOW.
>> GOT IT IN THE GLOVE.
THE ONE